case you missed it here's a quick recap
of the USA versus Iran World Cup match
it was a must win for the USA and the
Americans controlled possession right
from the start midfielders Tyler Adams
and Weston McKinney dominated and
created opportunities for Timothy waya
and sergino dest to put in dangerous
crosses in the 38th minute Christian
polisic put his body on the line quite
literally when he converted the header
from best before crashing into Iranian
keeper alireza birenbach
[Applause]
according to opposition Channel Iran
International there were also
celebrations from some anti-government
borders in Tehran just before halftime
USA almost got a second goal Timothy
waya found himself one-on-one with
birenbond and slotted it
but he was ruled outside and pulls this
Lounge
[Applause]
in the second half American goal scorer
Christian pulsich did not return after
his heavy collision with the keeper and
he was eventually taken to hospital Iran
brought on saman godos who had his
team's first real chance in the 51st
minute but his header went over the bar
he had another near Miss around 10
minutes later and it felt like Iran were
raising the intensity soon after U.S
Striker Josh Sargent stepped on the ball
and twisted his ankle ruling him out for
the rest of the match in the 80th minute
Iranian players appealed for a handball
in the box from U.S Defender Shaq Moore
the result would be a penalty but VAR
spotted no infringement in extra time
Iran's morteza puraliganji sent a diving
header just wide of Matt Turner's goal
nearly equalizing for Iran in the final
minutes Iran player swarmed the ref
looking for a penalty after Ford taremi
went down in the Box VAR once again said
no the results since Iran packing while
the US are through to the next round
where they'll face the Netherlands
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]